What is Microsoft Soundscape? Microsoft Soundscape is an app that is being
developed in partnership with Guide Dogs UK and is currently available for iOS.
Microsoft Soundscape provides information about your surroundings, helping
you to build a rich mental map of the cities and places you visit.
And it does this by using 3D audio. By simply connecting
any stereo headset, whether that be bluetooth or wired,
you'll experience rich 3D audio as you navigate the outdoor
world. Microsoft Soundscape is all about giving you choice.
Rather than dictate what you should do, the app allows you to
make your own decisions based on information being provided,
putting you in control. You can use Microsoft Soundscape in a number
of different ways, whether that be using it on a well-known route,
using it with a friend, or, if you're feeling more adventurous,
using it to discover new places you've never visited before.
During development, our trials and research show that Microsoft
Soundscape can help reduce levels of stress and anxiety,
giving people with sight loss more confidence when they're out and about in an urban environment.
Microsoft Soundscape, lighting up your world through sound.